[Music]
I'm going to give a somewhat broader
perspective going back some decades like
50 years and I don't think we need to go
50 years in the future but I'll try to
talk about what the key challenges are
as it stems from the history as I've
experienced it so 1962 when I was 14 I
wrote a letter to Marvin Minsky and
Frank Rosenblatt at Cornell the AI field
was already bifurcated into the
connectionist of symbolic schools Minsky
was recognized as the head of the
symbolic school though not widely known
that he actually created the personnel
that in the 1950s but he was already
skeptical of it by 1962 so both invited
me to come up
Minsky spent all day with me as if he
had nothing else to do he was the
consummate educator he wasn't thrilled
that I planned to go from from there to
Cornell to see Rosenblatt and I didn't
went to MIT he became my mentor for over
50 years until his passing earlier this
year in recent years he actually became
more enamored with the connectionist
school the symbolic school had a problem
which was not recognized in the early
60s that of the complexity ceiling get
to a point where the symbolic rules are
so complex you fix one thing and you
break two other things and unfortunately
that feeling that asymptotes is very
often much too low to solve various
problems I went up to Cornell perceptron
was getting a lot of excitement this is
probably the format of your time but
you're probably right about it had a
camera so I showed it
some images in courier 10 and it
recognized them I then took out a
different type fonts and also courier 10
in two different size it didn't
generalize in these people don't don't
worry we can feed the output of the
perceptron it was basically a single
layer neural net with backpropagation to
another perceptron and then he offered
that to another perceptron and we'll
generalize as we add additional layers
and ultimately would be able to solve
this problem and said Oh have you tried
that and says no but it's high on our
research agenda so he died nine years
later 1971
never having tried bad things could move
quite as quickly back then as they do
now it would actually be decades before
this intuition of Rosenblatt's would be
shown to be correct so decades later
multi-layer neural nets were used they
really couldn't go beyond much beyond
three layers they did generalize to some
extent but five six years ago the
challenge the AI feels what you guys
can't even tell the difference between a
dog and a cat and there was a problem
going beyond three levels because the
output of each layer is it has a error
surface that's a surface in in a
thousand dimensional space and you need
to keep that surface convex otherwise
the backpropagation gets stuck in a
local minima and it generally would not
it would asymptote also after about
three levels and three levels is not
quite enough that was a math problem a
group of mathematicians solve that
including one of my colleagues at Google
geoff hinton and was able to transform
the information after each level to keep
the error surface convex and now we
could go to any number of levels the
difference your dog and a cats actually
pretty subtle it's at level 15
approximately so now that we could go to
a few dozen layers these deep neural
Nets could tell the difference between a
dog and a cat we can now go to 100
levels
I read recently of a thousand layer
neural net at a hundred layers these for
example image recognition programs can
distinguish between thousands of
categories at about human levels of
performance in some cases better so this
breakthrough this math insight in being
able to go beyond three layers to any
number of layers is one of the factors
responsible for this tremendous surge of
competence and interest and performance
in AI the other is the result of the law
of accelerating returns that we are
getting exponentially more computation
data storage actual data that that along
with the ability to actually do these
deep neural nets is responsible for the
tremendous progress that we've seen by
the way the law if there are few
references to Moore's law people still
talk about Moore's law as if that
synonymous with the exponential
progression in information technology
it's not the law of accelerating returns
which basically says that the price
performance of information technology of
which computation is one progresses
exponentially that started decades
before Gordon Moore was born Moore's law
shrinking the size of features of
transistors with the fifth paradigm not
the first to bring exponential growth to
the price performance of computing and
that exponential progression also
applies to other information
technologies like communication or
genetic sequencing and so on for decades
now people think about Moore's Law is
going to come to an end saying ok but
we'll go then to the sixth paradigm that
has happened Moore's Law the shrinking
of transistor feature sizes has slowed
down the law of accelerating in turns
which is the exponential progression
expressible forints computing has not we
just updated our graph through like last
year and that continues we basically get
twice as much computation each year for
the same cause when our using going to
other paradigms like starting to go into
third dimension just lowering the cost
of producing transistors and so
on so that has accounted for the
tremendous progress we've seen but
there's still a few issues left one is
that you need a massive amount of data
to do supervised learning making some
progress and unsupervised learning but
it's nothing like the fantastic partners
we get with supervised learning there's
a motto in the connectionist field that
life begins at a billion examples and
one of the reasons I'm at Google is we
have a billion examples of some things
like images and like click data and
translated language data and so on but
we don't have it on some other things
and humans can learn from less data you
hear something once or twice from your
significant other or chairman of your
departments or your boss and you can
learn from that at least some humans do
that
but we don't always have a billion
examples so that's one weakness another
is it can be very slow lsdm which is a
very popular method of applying DNN deep
neural nets basically recomputes the
whole nest for each symbol in the
sequence and that can be very
time-consuming they don't explain
themselves very well we do discover at
the deeper level of a net some abstract
features the essence of a cow or dog
image for example but it's it's very
often hard to find those explanations
they're not self revealing and there's
another weakness which is escaping me
but so I've been interested in a
different somewhat different model which
is a hierarchy of sequential models and
actually wrote about that 50 years ago
in high school the systems we developed
with speech recognition in the 80s and
90s used hierarchical hidden Markov
models for the hidden Markov model
was the sequential model unlike lsdm it
doesn't do long term associations it
does local features but that's actually
what the brain is able to do so I wrote
a book how to create a mind came out
2012 that's one of the things that got
me recruited the Google talks about the
evidence we have from the neuroscience
field and also from observing human
brains in action as to why this why the
human neocortex is organized this way
for example the European a brain reverse
engineering project has identified
modules of about a hundred neurons each
there that are basically repeated over
and over again through the neocortex and
there's no plasticity within those
hundred neuron modules this plasticity
rewiring between the modules the
different project is actually found how
the modules connect to each other the
vertical and horizontal connections are
already there they're made live they're
activated when the neocortex decides to
connect this module to this module the
vertical and horizontal connections are
already there we actually have twice as
many of those as a newborn as as we do
as an adult the ones we never use die
out so and also we can observe human
brains in action
these Mazdas models are sequential and
then in an order so we can recite the
alphabet if I ask you to recite the
alphabet backwards you can't do that
once you learn that as a new sequence
that's one of the reasons we use
computers is to make up for these fairly
simple weaknesses of human intelligence
if I ask you to find some information
you might not be able to remember a
particular name because you have to
actually be in the right branch of the
right tree to retrieve information the
brain is not one big associative memory
if I give you a hint that helps you to
put you on the right branch then maybe
you can remember
so little hints like this I make the
case in how to create a mind that the
neocortex
is basically a big hierarchy of
sequential models the neocortex emerged
200 million years ago it's able to learn
new skills it can learn from a small
number of examples as I mentioned that's
one of the benefits something happened
two million years ago if you remember
two million years ago we were walking
around we didn't have these big
foreheads we had a slanted brow as
primates we then got evolution created
the frontal cortex and we get these big
foreheads and up until recently we
thought that it must be qualitatively
different must be organized differently
because it does different things it
turns out that it's really just an
additional quantity of neocortex this
has also been shown in these brain
reverse engineering projects the layer
that has the connections between the
modules has somewhat more connections in
the neocortex but otherwise it's the
same topology and organization of
neurons and it's basically learning a
sequential model with local patterns but
not long-term patterns long-term
relationships are learned by the
hierarchy itself so we got an additional
quantity of neocortex now what do we do
with that well we're already doing a
very good job of being primates so we
put it at the top of the neocortical
hierarchy and as you go up the hierarchy
issues get more abstract and more
interesting at the bottom of the
hierarchy I can tell that's a straight
line at the top of the hierarchy I can
tell that something is funny or
beautiful so that additional neocortex
was the enabling factor for us to invent
language in arts and science and
conferences music every human culture
we've ever discovered has music it's
actually on the universal art form no
other animal has music we could argue
about whale songs but basically music is
came with that additional neocortex the
same with humor now that was a one-shot
deal we couldn't
to increase the size of the neocortex it
already made childbirth challenging
maybe there were a few humans that had
more near cortex but their offspring
couldn't be born because their skulls
were too big so it's a one-shot deal but
it put it over that threshold so that we
could invent for example technology and
that's formed its own accelerating
exponential process so we're going to do
it again because the law of accelerating
in terms of computer on my belt is
billions of times more powerful per
dollar than a computer I use when I went
to MIT I went to MIT because MIT was so
advanced in the late 1960s it actually
had a computer this is millions of times
less expensive it's thousands of times
more powerful it's a several billion
fold increase in the price performance
of computation but that's actually not
the most interesting thing about it I
can expand the capabilities of this
thousands fold I connect a thousand
times more computation by connecting
wirelessly to the cloud millions of
times more in terms of accessing
information so kid in Africa with a
smartphone can access all of human
knowledge with a few keystrokes we can't
do that yet directly from my neocortex
we do it indirectly through these
devices but in the future once we
develop strong AI and I'm going to come
back to talk about one I think that will
happen that will be in the cloud and we
will connect our neocortex to a
synthetic neocortex in the cloud and
just as this multiplies itself thousands
or millions fold by connecting
wirelessly to similar computation in the
clouds we will do that with our
neocortex simulated neocortical modules
so I'm walking along in 2035 and I look
up and cell is max tegmark it's coming
my way I better think of something
clever to say I've got two seconds by
300 million near cortical module isn't
going to cut it I need a billion or ten
billion for two seconds I'll be able
access that just the way your phone does
that when it needs to
as a something to do a search where it
needs additional computation so just as
we did two million years ago we will
extend our neocortex and have addition
additional quantity of new cortex and
just as we did two million years ago
we'll put it at the top of the
neocortical hierarchy so we will be more
musical will be funnier will basically
exemplifies the things that we value
but unlike two million years ago it
won't be a one-shot deal the cloud is
subject to the law of accelerating
insurance it is doubling in power every
year as we speak that will continue so
ultimately the bulk of our thinking I
thinking there will be a hybrid of
biological and non-biological thinking
it's a non-biological part of the
subject to the law of accelerating
returns it will expand without limit
ultimately will predominate so let me
come back and talk about when I think we
will achieve human-level intelligence at
Google I've been implementing my ideas
of hierarchical sequential models were
preparing some papers work and talk in
more detail about the actual results but
we are finding that it's orders of
magnitude faster than lsdm that can
learn for much fewer examples it can
explain itself and this is the other
weakness of that we found with lsdm is
it can do certain semantic distinctions
I think if you can do language you can
do everything I believe things inside of
basing it's a basic test of human
intelligence based on language I think
languages doing complete we find that
Alice cam can't quite it does do some
semantic distinctions but not others
we're finding more success with
sequential hierarchical models and so
we're going to continue to move in that
direction so in terms of the future I
think there's general agreements that
were close to the hardware requirements
of strong AI we're they're already
attempts but not at a reasonable cost I
think will be a point where a human
equivalent is about a thousand dollars
the early 2020s in my view that's 1014
calculations per second
I've got derivations of that in my book
Hans Moravec comes to the same
conclusion using a whole different
approach other some estimates are 10 to
the 16th but the hardware problem is is
well in hand the software problem is
more complex one of the points I make is
that software progress is also
exponential and there's a lot of
evidence of that it was actually study
done by the White House Science Advisory
Board on this issue we've gotten more
benefits from hardware software on a
range of our 20 engineering problems and
they found that software actually
contributed more in terms of algorithmic
improvements that comes in fits and
starts it's not quite as steady as the
law of accelerating returns applied to
hardware but I make the case that we
will get there by 2029 so I I've had
that prediction going back to 1989 in my
first book agent tells the machines I
had that date within a decade or so I
said specifically 2029 by 1999 book age
of Scripture age of spiritual machines
Stanford had a conference about this
startling prediction of AI experts and
the consensus then we didn't have
polling machines or online polls there
was a show of hands but the consensus
was 500 years that was the median some
people thought it would never happen
recently I've seen different analyses
and polls of AI experts have range
between 30 years and 50 years so takes
50 years but the reason for that advance
if you will bringing in the date is the
law of accelerating returns but in my
view it's not that people are really
internalizing exponential growth they're
looking at the current rate of growth
Sangji it's the current rate well in
1999 people who trades can take 500
years now people looking at the current
rate saying at this rate of progress
we'll get there in 50 years I agree with
that
except that we're going to accelerate
that rate of progress that is not
factored in with
make fifty years of progress at today's
rate in about 13 years and people linear
thinking linear extras as expositions of
the future strap elations is really
hardwired so let me just in the last
minute give a foolproof plan to keep AI
beneficial so these future futurist AI
dystopian movies have it's the AI versus
the humans for control of humanity and
that's not a realistic vision even of
today we don't have one or two a eyes in
the world we have billions of AIS in the
world and that's going to get even more
intimate when I was at MIT a to take
like bicycles across campus to get to
the computer now we all carry them
around they're going to go inside our
bodies and brains are going to keep it's
healthy they're going to go inside our
neocortex connect to synthetic neocortex
in the clouds it's going to be a very
intimate integration so AI is not not an
invasion of intelligent machines for
Mars this is technology we create to
extend ourselves that's always been the
role of Technology and we're going to
continue to do that and intimately
integrate with it so here's the plan I
believe we have more of a consensus on
values and we think things like
democracy Liberty tolerance compassion
we could have a whole conference on that
that was not the case centuries ago even
one century ago there are only five
democracies in the world so the plan is
let's integrate these values on which I
believe we largely have a consensus in
our society today the future society the
one that's dominated by AI the one which
AI is intimately integrated with our
existence will emerge from today's
society until we embody those values
today the future society will also
embody them what could go wrong thank
you
honey Richard Sutton yeah I thank you
for your presentation as I was really
clear concisely making all these main
points but I wanted to ask you about in
your theory of how we're making the mind
the hierarchical sequential models there
isn't it doesn't seem to be an explicit
role for further four goals and and and
or something like rewards or values in
it and can you sort of explain how
because we all care about the value
pardon and the purpose is how does that
fit in it isn't normally part of what
you call it hidden Markov models yeah
you'd agree well I agree that that it's
not obvious that these hierarchical
sequential models which are basically
pattern recognition mods models would
apply to things like planning and
reasoning I maintain that they do a plan
is a sequence of goals and they each
break down into sub goals and we're
showing that we can actually do that
kind of goal tracking and pursuit with a
with an appropriate hierarchical model I
believe that's how we think I've always
thought that there was actually very
little neuroscience evidence 50 years
ago there's actually quite a bit now we
contain these modules that they have
axons coming in from other modules and
that it is basically organized as a as a
hierarchy of of these muds
of these modules and the modules are
doing sequential pattern recognition and
I talked about in the book it's a longer
explanation but basically plans are
hierarchies we have we want to
accomplish certain things each of these
so composed of sub goals and it all
breaks down into a hierarchy of goals
ultimately we try to match reality to
the goals and see where it differs and
then what we need to do to realize each
sub goal um ya know coup
okay max team to tell me and tells me
and to go to set up um so actually
wasn't that actually tried multiple
layers he just didn't
the running algorithm for it so there
are several papers by him and his team
with perception with you know four or
five six layers followed by a trainable
layers because he didn't have backdrop
you didn't have that propagation he had
B Square but I mean not e Square the
perception algorithm but he didn't have
back prop you know back pop popped up in
the control theory figured it out in the
60s it popped up in machine learning in
the 70s but nobody paid attention and
then it was popularized in the 80s and
there were neural nets with multiple
layers already there commercial Nets in
1989 had you know seven eight layers
come you know recurrent Nets that you're
given and you are working on at lots of
layers of course because they were kind
of unfolded in time and and so what
happened in in two thousand ten eleven
twelve is not a mathematical
breakthrough but a practical
breakthrough people realized they could
run those things in a much bigger scale
on GPUs with the large training set so
there were kind of a few conceptual
ideas like using values instead of
sigmoid it doesn't make the cost
function convex at all it still very non
convex but there are properties that
your show and I have been working on
mathematical theories that shows that
this non convexity is not a problem
actually you don't you don't get trapped
in local minima so you know it's just
kind of a slight historical correction
and channeling jörgen here but well we
okay wait we could debate that in my
view though there was a mathematical
issue that prevented us going beyond
just a few layers and you know once we
could freely go to one hundreds layers
and it was not just GPUs I think there
was a mathematical issue that does have
to do with the convexity our surface but
we that's probably not of great interest
to the group but you're in one sentence
just adding something to be very
interesting comment of a yawns I enjoyed
greatly your reminiscence of what
happened when you met Minsky back then
and he is often credited with with
killing your neural network research
because he wrote this book in 1969 about
the limitations of the shallow networks
you know one day a perceptron but that
was four years after the fact because of
course there was the famous
mathematician from the Ukrainian Eva
clinco Alexei Gregorovitch Arachne
Gork who had deep learning networks in
1965 with his students lapa multi-layer
perceptrons eight layers you know and I
learned not back pop but incremental
learning and it worked and was a popular
algorithm until 2000 something else well
I wrote in 1999 and H scriptural
machines that the theorem in Minsky and
Papert spoke perceptrons in 1969 only
applied to single layer girl nets that
basically couldn't tell the
connectedness problem and Minsky was
quite literally opposed I think he
didn't like the hype that perceptrons
were getting at that time he actually
took out of the book a lot of visceral
ranting against neural nets he later on
when I took them more recently regretted
the success of that book in killing a
lot of funding for twenty years and he
became actually quite enthusiastic
because of the tremendous progress
that's been made in this field
[Music]